today's video is sponsored by dashlane
you guys can get 50 off the cost of a
dashlane premium plan more on them in
just a bit
every once in a while a story comes
along that seems too good to be true
that can't be real you think that has
to be made up but
yet incredibly sometimes it isn't such
is the case with john paul jones
america's first naval hero this
swashbuckling character from the last
years of the age of sale looks like he
walked right off the page in an
adventure novel and he certainly had his
share of adventures born in scotland
sailing under the flag of the united
states fated by french royalty and
kissing the hand of the empress of
russia he wasn't the kind of man you'd
want as your boss demanding
temperamental light on praise and heavy
on criticism even his closest confidant
privately thought he was self-centered
and boring but in command of a ship
especially in the heart of battle his
skill was unmatched the british
dismissed him as a pirate but they were
also immensely afraid of what he might
do to them his victories over the
british royal navy the most powerful the
world had ever seen was so spectacular
people were still talking about them
centuries after they happened so much so
that his example is still followed by
the modern iteration of the united
states army
in the southwestern corner of scotland
situated along the solway firth that
forms part of its historic border with
england lies county galloway one of the
many plum sea side estates that lined
the coast of galloway was arbi lands
owned by a man named william craig
craig's well-respected gardener a man
named john paul lived in a comfortable
cottage not far from the main house a
barbecueland and is there that john and
his wife jean welcomed their fourth
child also named john paul into the
world on july 6 1747. john paul jr as he
was known then certainly had a pleasant
childhood at our big land as he had
nothing but foreign memories of the
place in his later life but his
ambitions were set higher than that of a
gardener like many boys his age he
craved adventure and a few things were
more adventurous in those days than a
career at sea the lack of affluent
connections kept him from a commission
in the royal navy to that institution's
later regret so instead he signed on
with the merchant marines in 1761 aged
13 the common age to start an
apprenticeship in those days after a
number of years cruising back and forth
across the atlantic in trading vessels
in 1768 john found himself stuck in
kingston jamaica without a job he'd quit
his last job in disgust upon arrival and
it isn't hard to see why sailing on
board a slave ship was an unpleasant
business even if a man didn't find the
practices of slavery and abominable
trade as john paul later confessed he
did left with attaway to get home he
accepted the offer of a free passage
back to scotland on board the tiny brig
john and it's here where fortune first
smiled upon our hero on the trip home
both the master and the first mate of
the ship died of illness and the ship
was thrown into a panic because nobody
else on board knew how to navigate an
important yet complex skill for a sailor
to learn in the 18th century nobody that
was except for their passenger john paul
who took over command and skillfully
guided the vessel back home the briggs
owners were so grateful that they gave
him the job of commanding the ship
permanently at the tender age of 21 the
young man was on his way
the young captain's first brush with
trouble came in 1770 at the end of his
second voyage in command of john paul at
the ship's carpenter mungo maxwell
flogged with a whip for an offense
committed on board maxwell complained to
authorities in tobago that the captain
was unnecessarily cruel in his
punishment which was dismissed but that
wasn't the end of the story while
traveling home on board another ship
maxwell became ill and died when
maxwell's father heard what had happened
he decided that his son's death had been
caused by the flogging despite no
evidence that the two incidents were
related when paul returned to scotland
he was arrested and imprisoned to await
trial on murder charges fortunately
though he was able to make bell a few
days later and received permission from
the court to travel to tobago to acquire
affidavits attesting to his innocence in
the matter which was quietly dropped
later for lack of evidence but the story
that he had once flogged a man to death
would follow him for the rest of his
career captain paul moved on to bigger
and better things specifically command
of the larger ship betsy with which he
did a brisk business over the course of
the next two years building himself a
small fortune in the process a few more
years of this could have seen paul save
up enough money to retire from the
lonesome and dangerous business of
seafaring to live the life he really
wanted that of a gentleman farmer not
unlike william craig of arab england
when he grew up but a deadly incident
aboard his ship changed the entire
trajectory of his life while dr tobago
in october 1773 the crew of the betsy
asked the captain for partial payment of
their wages so they could spend it on
shore probably in the mana sailors on
shores are want to do on alcohol and
women of ill repute but the captain
short on cash wanting to preserve what
he had to invest in the return cargo
refused insisting that they would all be
paid the full amount once the ship
returned to london this sent the crew
into a rage and a brawl broke out
between one of the sailors and captain
paul that ended when the captain ran the
man through with his sword killing him
paul would always claim the killing had
been done in self-defense but that man
whose name has been lost to history was
popular with the local island populace
and that not fear of judicial punishment
was what compelled him to flee tobago
leaving his ship his money and almost
all of his worldly possessions behind
one wonders if there might be more to
this story since the only definitive
account we have at the incident comes
from a letter the captain wrote years
later but we will most likely never know
what really happened in any case our
hero ended up in america living inside
his dead brother's house in
friedrichsburg virginia already he had
decided to change his name going by jon
jones for a time while he laid low and
waited for the tobago incident to blow
over at some point he evidently decided
to simply use both his original surname
and his new one at the same time and for
the rest of his life he was known as
john paul jones alright we'll get back
to today's video in a second but first
here's a word from today's sponsor
dashlane perhaps you notice that like me
you spend a lot of time on the internet
maybe you're on youtube google and you
know all of the streaming services stuff
like that look i don't know about you
but it's hard for me to remember all the
passwords to all of those things perhaps
you can relate dashlane gives you more
time and better security by storing all
of your password payment information and
personal information in a secure place
that only you can access and when you
want that information to log into an
account or buy something boom it auto
fills super easily in just a single
click dashlane is powered by patented
security technology and machine learning
which is why it consistently ranks as
the best password manager available no
matter the device or browser that you're
using it makes every shopping experience
a one-click checkout stores all your
passwords so you're never locked out of
an account and provides a vpn for
streaming content and secure browsing
brilliant in essence it's the essential
tool for your home or your business when
using the internet right now you can try
it for free on your first device by
going to dashlane.com forward slash bio
50. use my promo code buy a 50 to get 50
off an upgrade to a premium plan across
an unlimited number of devices you can't
do better than that grab yourself some
dashlane and now let's get back to
today's video
[Music]
jones's flight to america came just as
the dispute between the 13 colonies and
the mother country had been growing
increasingly ugly both sides continued
to up the ante until violence erupted in
massachusetts in april 1775. the
continental congress were not formally
declaring themselves independent just
yet still sought to defend themselves
from britain's aggression by creating a
continental army commanded by george
washington and a corresponding
continental navy commanded by a rhode
island sailor named essec hopkins the
new navy needed experienced sailors to
serve his officers and john paul jones
just happened to be a very experienced
sailor in desperate need of a new job it
was a match made in heaven in august
1775 jones traveled to philadelphia to
seek a naval commission it took him a
few months but he got one in december
being appointed as a first lieutenant
and given a temporary ship command the
continental navy was in trouble from the
very beginning for a number of reasons
its opponent the british royal navy was
without question the world's best and
most powerful with her chief rivals in
france spain and the netherlands all
lagging far behind for over a century
the crowd had invested heavily in her
wooden walls to protect the island's
country from invasion and to oversee the
vast trade network that stretched across
the world and made london the richest
city in europe by contrast the americans
had to start totally from scratch since
it wasn't like the british kept spare
warship sitting around for them to take
and they were perpetually short of
everything sales cannons gun powder and
especially manpower in addition to the
continental navy congress and the
individual colonies gave letters of bark
to private ships to serve as privateers
on their behalf this practice a form of
legalized piracy authorized privateers
to capture enemy shipping and keep the
proceeds which provided the dual benefit
of hurting the enemy's commercial
interest at minimal government expense
the problem was for a sailor service on
a privateer was much preferable to duty
on a naval vessel discipline was more
lacks it was generally safer and it paid
much better as a result the continental
navy would struggle to recruit sailors
for the duration of the revolutionary
war
jones spent 1776 engaged in various
naval adventures following a stint as
first lieutenant aboard a converted
merchant ship alfred where he
participated in a surprise raid on
nassau in the bahamas he was given
command of the slu providence and
ordered to conduct similar business in
newfoundland home to british fishing
vessels this was a very profitable
venture for both jones and his group the
practice of capturing enemy ships as
prizes sending them to friendly ports
and selling the ship and cargo for prize
money was a very lucrative business in
the age of sale successful captains made
far more money from prizes than from
monthly pay and so did everyone else on
board after this he made another cruise
as commander of alfred taking more
prizes and doing more damage to british
shipping while slipping out of the hands
of various royal navy vessels that tried
to stop him in these cruises he showed
his superior seamanship but also his
inability to get along with other people
commodore hopkins received so many
complaints from men who served unto
jones about his conduct that he wrote to
congress saying that it was going to be
difficult to convince anyone to serve
under him again this wasn't just driven
by jones incredible temper but also by
regionalism on the part of the americans
in a world where everyone knew all their
neighbors and didn't trust anyone from
the next county over to do riot by them
jones was a foreigner a stranger in
america who nobody knew the solution
according to john hancock president of
the congress was to send jones to france
where benjamin franklin was conducting a
treaty of alliance with king louis xvi
the french had promised to support the
americans by providing war material
including ships and the thought was to
send captain jones to command one of
those but how to get him there jones was
offered command of a newly completed
sloop ranger that was being fitted out
in portsmouth new hampshire after much
trouble getting her ready for sea ranger
finally left port in november 1777. just
over a month later captain jones was in
paris what would become his favorite
place on earth he took to french culture
immediately the fine food and wine the
elegance and majesty of the court of
versailles and of course the many sexual
intrigues of french noble women he also
took to 70 year old ben franklin leader
of the american delegation to france and
already the most talked about man in
europe they had much in common franklin
also appreciated the finer points of
parisian society and all the delights
carnal and otherwise that came wisdom
franklin jones tried to get a suitable
new ship for him out of the french but
nothing came of it perhaps in order to
get their new allies attention an
example was needed of what the new
american navy was capable of and jones
had the perfect idea
we will never know what john paul
jones's capabilities were as a strategic
planner of naval operations since he was
never in command of a large battle fleet
at any point in his career but the plan
he put forward suggests that had he been
given the chance he would have excelled
at it jones knew that his country's navy
would never be able to go gun to gun
with the royal navy they couldn't defend
their own coastline from blockade they
would have to rely on their french
allies for that but what the americans
could do was attack places that weren't
well defended and forced them to stretch
their resources the more ships that were
detached to defend the west indies for
instance the fewer that could be used to
harass american ports captain jones
proposed something even more audacious
to raid the british coastline itself to
tweak the nose of the lion he would make
the british public howl so loudly that
the royal navy would have to send an
entire fleet to chase after him with no
better ship in the offing jones returned
to ranger which wasn't particularly
happy to see him her crew wanted to go
home and if they couldn't do that they
wanted to hunt merchant vessels to chase
prize money like privateers they
certainly didn't want to follow after
mad jones and his crazy schemes that was
exactly what they had to do when ranger
got underway in april 1778. he boldly
sailed into the irish sea the very heart
of enemy territory ranger tailed around
with impunity for a few days not drawing
attention to herself while jones waited
on an opportunity when no ships appeared
that he could take jones decided to try
something even more bold he would raid
the english seaboard of whitehaven on
the solway firth he was intimately
familiar with the ports since it was
where he'd first sailed out of back when
he'd first joined the merchant marines
and he knew it was home to a large
fishing plate on the night of april 22nd
1778 jones led a raiding party of 40 men
ashore where they spiked the cannons of
the fort and set fire to as many of the
ships as they could in the harb before
being chased off by a mob of townspeople
who fired wildly at them as they rode
back to the ranger the fires were soon
extinguished and the actual damage done
was minimal but it was the first time a
hostile force had landed on british
shores in over a hundred years and it
sent its citizenry into panic jones was
not done yet the next day he sailed to
mary's al on the other side of the first
attempting to kidnap the earl of selkirk
in order to exchange him for american
naval prisoners being held in british
jails as pirates upon discovering the
earl was not home his men carried off
the household silver plate as booty the
day after that the americans spotted hms
drake a 20-gun sloop and allowed her to
come within pistol range before opening
fire after a fight that lasted for an
hour drake surrendered after a captain
and first mate were both killed jones
sailed back to france after that prize
in tow easily evading the royal navy
ships dispatched to intercept him and
leaving chaos in his wake
[Music]
if the british thought that jones first
cruise into their waters was bad they
hadn't seen anything yet in august 1779
jones prepared to sorty again after a
year of preparations having sent ranger
back to the united states jones was
given a new ship by the french bert
chipman converted into a 40-gun warship
the ship was christened bonhoen richard
in honor of benjamin franklin using the
french translation of his pen name poor
richard four other ships made up
commodore jones's raiding squadron who
planned to repeat his performance from a
year before on a grander scale his
mission was supposed to be a distraction
from a planned invasion of southeast
england by the french army and navy
which ended up never getting underway as
disease devastated the sailors packed on
the warships but jones didn't let this
deter him he sailed up the western coast
of ireland and scotland taking prizes as
he went before heading into the north
sea and sailing down the eastern coast
of scotland in september his squadron
appeared in the firth of fourth
intending to hold the town of laith to
ransom leith was the principal port of
the city of edinburgh which despite
being the historic capital and largest
city in scotland was woefully
under-defended scotland not being
permitted a militia since a failed
rebellion against king george in 1745.
only a contrary wind prevented jones
from either collecting a rich ransom or
laying waste to the town with heated
cannonballs that would set it afar on
september 23 1779 jones squadron was
south of the city of scarborough sailing
around a spit of land known as flambera
head this is when the lookout spotted
something a large merchant convoy of 40
ships was coming in from the baltic if
jones could capture even a few of these
floating treasure chests he and his men
would be rich beyond all imagination but
the merchantmen were being guarded by
two royal navy vessels which would have
to be dealt with first the leadership of
the convoy was hms serapis a newly built
frigate of 50 guns her captain richard
pearson positioned her so she was
between the convoy and the enemy
squadron making it obvious that he
intended to fight it was like a red flag
in front of a bull for john paul jones
one of the most celebrated battles in
u.s navy history was about to take place
it was dark by the time the combatants
had closed on each other a nearly full
moon rising over relatively calm seas
jones and bonhomme richard faced off
against serapis while his support
vessels took on the other warship the 20
gun counters of scarborough the battle
started off badly for the americans one
of richard's cannons exploded killing
many sailors and doing a great deal of
damage the gun deck not trusting his
remaining cannons jones realized his
only chance of victory was to grapple
alongside the serapis and board her the
british meanwhile poured broadside after
broadside into the bonhomme richard
killing more men both ships engaged in a
series of frantic maneuvers to gain an
advantage colliding with each other
several times during one of these
clinches the british captain asked if
jones had struck his colours which would
indicate he wished to surrender jones
replied heatedly i have not yet begun to
fight
and he hadn't the two ships collided
again this time getting stuck exactly
what jones wanted the americans fired
muskets and threw hand grenades onto the
deck of serapis soon causing the british
decks to run red with blood it was an
uncommonly violent struggle for naval
combat of the period and it lasted a
long time over three hours at one point
a rumor went around recharged that jones
was dead and a junior officer went
looking for the ship's colours not
realizing that they'd been shot away in
the fighting jones was not dead merely
exhausted and he pulled out a pistol
apparently ready to shoot the offending
officer who dared to contemplate
surrendering his ship he thought better
of it though merely throwing the gun of
the man instead knocking him down at one
point one of the other american ships
alliance came alongside the struggle and
looking to help fired her cannons in the
direction of serapis unfortunately the
broadsides did as much damage to
bonhomme richard as it did to the
british it led to later speculation that
alliance's captain who hated jones had
deliberately fired in his commander's
vessel to try and kill him and therefore
take the glory for himself finally a
terrific explosion tore through the
lower decks of serapis killing and
wounding many sailors a lucky grenade
tars had landed in a pile of unscrewed
gunpowder bags igniting them that
effectively ended the fight as captain
pearson soon called for quarters jones
had captured therapists but it had cost
him his own ship bonom richard had so
many holes blown in her that water was
coming in faster than it could be pumped
out the next day the order was given to
abandoned ship and jones sadly watched
as the brave ship slipped beneath the
waves the merchant fleet on the other
hand made it to port safely with only
the two royal navy ships lost
[Music]
the capture of serapis was the high
point of john paul jones's career though
he was honored by both the french and
american government jealous intrigue
from fellow navy captains prevented him
from being promoted to the rank of rear
admiral he was also left without a ship
to command as most of the continental
navy had been destroyed or captured and
what wasn't was sold off or scrapped
after the war ended in 1783. maintaining
it was simply too expensive for the
fledging republic's finances to bear
jones would eventually become an admiral
in the imperial russian navy of
catherine the great she was hiring
foreign naval officers to serve in our
war against the ottoman empire and not
many of them especially not the british
ones were eager to serve alongside jones
the pirate jones himself made things
worse with his abrasive personality and
soon a campaign was underway to ruin his
reputation he was accused of rape by a
girl in some petersburg probably a
prostitute frequented by jones who was
put up to it by his political enemies
though he was eventually cleared of the
charge the scandal proved the end of his
russian naval career doane spent the
last years of his life in paris now
greatly changed by the convulsions of
the french republic it was a sad
existence living in an apartment alone
with almost no friends and few people to
keep him company consummate sailor had
many mistresses throughout his life but
never married and if he had any bastard
children out there that he acknowledged
it has escaped the notice of historians
the truth was nobody wanted to talk to
jones anymore because they found him
boring for all his talents the man had a
truly colossal ego and all it seemed he
ever wanted to talk about was himself he
select contacts in america most
importantly secretary of state thomas
jefferson and if his health hadn't
failed him he might have been able to
come back into the spotlight but alas it
was not to be on july the 18th 1792
jones died of kidney inflammation at the
age of 45. he was buried in a protestant
cemetery outside the city his grave
built over after the cemetery closed
during the reign of napoleon that might
have been the end of the story but in
1905 the u.s ambassador to france horace
porter sponsored a project to find
jones's remains the pressure officials
had taken the precaution to bury jones
in a lead coffin in case the united
states ever wanted to repatriate his
remains over a century later when the
coffin was on earth the body was so well
preserved pathologists were able to
perform an autopsy on it then jones was
buried across the atlantic on board the
uss brooklyn to annapolis maryland
annapolis is home to the u.s naval
academy and president theodore roosevelt
famous advocate for u.s naval power
believed there was no better place for
the country's first naval hero to be
laid to rest after all in the hundred
years since jones death the u.s navy had
become one of the mightiest in the world
and the exploits of john paul jones were
celebrated in navy law in a way that
they weren't when he was alive in 1913
jonpal jones was formally interred in an
elaborate marble and bronze tomb
underneath the academy chapel surrounded
by his laurels and mementos of his
battles the inscription on the floor of
his crypt reads he gave our navy its
earliest traditions heroism and victory
a fitting epitaph for the man often
referred to as the father of the united
states navy
[Music]
now just before you leave today maybe
looking for something else to watch why
not check out my new channel called wara
graphics want to know all of the details
about some of history's most famous
battles and wars come join me on war of
graphics from sherman's march to the sea
to operation barbarossa it's got people
fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link
below